تحدي استقبال الزوار والمشجعين وضمان
سلامتهم يبدو كبيرا هنا يبدو جليا الحرص
على الوصول الى قمه الجاهزيه فالتظاهرات
الرياضيه الدوليه مثل كاس العالم هي دائما
مصدر تحديات امنيه بالنسبه الى البلد
المنظم لجسد هذا المركز التكامل في
الادوار والمسؤوليات والمهام بين الجهات
المدنيه والعسكريه اثناء البطوله ان
المركز متصل باكثر من 150,000 كاميرا تعرض
جميع ما هو في الميدان لتسهيل اتخاذ
القرار للقياده طبعا البطوله هذه
استثنائيه بالاكل ستلاحظ الجماهير ذلك من
لحظه
واستعمل القوات على مدار الساعه على ضمان
امن وسلامه الجماهير لتقديم نسخه مميزه
امنه لحدث الاستثنائيه اجراءات واستعدادات
استثنائيه فاستقباله الاف المشجعين
والزوار لضمان لام وايضا لضمان سلامتهم هو
من نوع تلك التحديات الكبيره ذات الطبيعه
المختلفه
هذا ملعب البيت اختير ليشهد افتتاح
المونديال كل شيء فيه بات جاهزا للحدث
الذي يتشوق اليه عشاق الكره هنا ستكون في
حوزه الجهه المختصه تجهيزات متطوره
باستطاعتها معالجه اي حادث بسرعه فائقه تم
اختبار الخطا العده سنوات والتعديلات اللي
كان تم عليها نقدر نقول ولا اله الحمد انه
اليوم الملعب جاهز الاستضافه الجماهير
وجميع الوفود اللي قادم من كل الاغطاب
بالعالم في هذا اليوم المنشود باذن الله
وانكد لهم ان جميع الخضرواتنا وجميع
الموارد المتوفره من صوبنا احنا كلها على
تم الجهازيه والاستعدادات الاستضافات
خصصت السلطات المعنيه وحده لاستشراف
المخاطر والتهديدات هنا يجري يوميا تقييم
التهديدات والمخاطر المحتمله والرهان على
الوقايه واحتواء ايطار امني يمتلك فريق
التفاوض مهارات التفاضيه عاليه تساعد
الفريق من خلال المشاركه في الاحداث التي
تتطلب مشاركه فريق التفاوض وايضا تدربنا
وشاركنا في عده سيناريوهات مختلفه ومتنوعه
وكان مثالها من خلال مشاركتنا في تمرين
وطن 2022 حيث شاركنا في عده سيناريات
مختلفه ومعقده وكانت الامانه صعبه جدا
ولكن اثبت الفريق على ان نستعد وعلى هبه
الاستعداد
والمشاركه في الاحداث التي تتطلب مشاركه
فريق التفاوض
في الاسابيع الاخيره تسارعا نسق
الاستعدادات في الفضاءات ذات الصله ليكون
مونديال قطر الاكثر امنا وامانا نوردين
بوزيان الجزيره الدوحه